real big horse yeah there are credit
lost a lot of weight though not a lot of
weight I'm trying to lose a lot of
weight look a tremor I thank you very
much I'm playing the new um what do you
what wait what were you gonna say now I
don't know I'm not supposed to but it's
another movie what is the movie now no
please
nope no because I can already tell
please be honest now I am on I'm an
honest guy in my friend a woman lie to
you okay so who what are you playing
yeah the new I see I was I've already
said too much
well I saw you now people can Google all
the old satchels mounting the new your
mouth went and you you were gonna make a
B sound yeah you're right I was gonna
say a B now maybe I can maybe maybe you
can just nod your head or shake it now I
want you to be careful though cuz it's
gonna there are people listening and you
don't want to lie now right yeah but
I'll are you talking about nodding my
head or shaking my head yeah so and feel
like we're back in the corner
maybe you misspoke for a second so not a
big deal if you misspoke and you can
just say no right with this yeah right
were you gonna say that you're relaxed
relaxed
what were you gonna say that you're
playing the new Batman you can say no
hold on there's a small nod at the end
of the shake so no right no I'm not
putting nothing mom okay good you're not
gonna matter I'm playing someone else
and it's a lot of people think that the
part would have gone a different
direction a lot of people are thinking
perhaps it's time for a woman to play
the role yeah
there's been talk of Idris Elba playing
the role but the role has an actor in
Africa yeah yeah in Africa Brian just
said but yeah that's an Africa actor no
yeah that's racist to say in Africa
that's not what we okay who is that
who's that friend ears who comes by a
plea plays poker with the guys
he's got his daughters on the softball
team with you oh the Mexico don't do
that right I don't know yeah yeah I know
I know you just you just we talked about
a movie that I'm in that's a really
serious drama yeah you talked about the
two women and now you want yeah Merrigan
wha mom no it's okay is that the
soundtrack
that's the Lenny Kravitz version no um
I'm not Batman Robert Pattinson is
Batman No
oh whatever that's a great choice Robert
he'll do great that [ __ ] guy is not
Batman I'll beat him up right now what
are we talking about well Bryan Callen
wasn't available you got that guy you
got that guy with Bryan Callen a 52
year-old not around I mean he's a
good-looking guy blaze he he's really
good-looking kid he's got very intense
eyes yeah but but but yeah I don't look
at him as being Batman's a tough [ __ ]
yeah but they gotta like read a read a
character for the younger generation huh
you know couldn't they have found a dude
who did one sport he played werewolf he
did he played vampire and werewolf isn't
that that he played in a [ __ ] vampire
yeah but that's yeah no no there were
two teams there was team vampire team
werewolf and no more pictures I never
saw the movie but apparently was a sport
movies he in shape huh is he in shape or
he's got a dance his physique I want my
people you know it's interesting Brian
you're talking about being in shape
you're talking about dancers physique
you got your body's look sort of similar
in that you have you know to [ __ ]
it's a belly button working out a lot at
least but it's just still not I mean I
just need a different it's time for a
new it's time for a new outlook on on
ourselves our physical selves and as you
know the body positivity movement is
what is making great gains the body posi
movement okay the body posi movement
right and so one of the things that's
happening is we're seeing it reflected
in our media whether it's the internet
whether it's the magazines that you buy
as everyone buys magazines yeah
or the movies you watch yeah you know
women are speaking a lot about you know
wanting to feel good in the skin that
they're in sure men too and this role
I'm really that I'm taking on I'm really
I'm really proud of the makers and I'm
proud of the I'm proud of actually of
the history of the part and and that
it's now come full circle circle but say
you're the new Bond and the new James
Bond okay now I'm the new Bond alright
James and I haven't seen any of the
films but that's apparently they say
that well because I said it at the
audition they go you got the part kid
and I went I'm the new Bond and they go
yeah and I go James I said they they are
you sure they said you're the new James
Bond for the movies yes I'm Roger Moore
and Roger Moore Sean Connery Timothy
Dalton the new here's Brosnan you're the
new Bond uh what was the other guy Craig
Daniel Craig right so you're the new
Bond yes now I'm gonna give you a chance
or Lazenby
do you have any proof of this can you
bring up Will Sasso - yeah why don't you
google it but see this is what this is
what's interesting about breaking some
big news on the podcast okay
it's not gonna be anywhere in Google
this is a world exclusive but please
feel free well you just said it's not
gonna be anywhere on Google yeah because
I'm breaking the news here I'm actually
not supposed to talk about it when did
this come out a couple days ago so yeah
there's nothing there no there's not
there's something about American woman
on the top right because yeah there's
nothing I don't see yeah no there's
nothing
yeah there's nothing about because I'm
just because I'm breaking the news here
okay and are you gonna use an English
accent huh oh yeah no they mentioned
they said something about that look it's
more about two things it's more about
that you know bond was generally a very
very nominated shaped guy but this is
what I'm talking about
wedding oh well let's just go with your
hands first of all he shoots a small gun
yeah no way do your fingers fit no way
does that finger fit in the hole of a
Walther PPK sure it does it just there's
no way than a Walther PPK I don't know
what that is you're making it sound like
I got a bigger PPK I got the kind of
fingers that look like sausages that are
busted on the barbecue when you leave
them on the inside you're like we're
good with the chicken
yeah leave the sausages on the grill and
then yeah that's a Walther PPK that's
what that's you so what's that thing
weigh about 14 15 pounds what's it about
that big no you don't know guns that's a
tiny gun what and you can you can fit it
for a silencer if you if you've got the
machinery all right but let's see is it
your finger doesn't fit in that one of
my fingers we'll try an okay listen it's
not I'm not worried about that we'll get
a bigger gun they'll make it bigger and
we'll break other boundaries with this
roll of bond well like this one you know
generally bond has been an in shape guy
of one sort of stature now it's more
this now it's gonna be a real dude
no I'm saying another thing is
traditionally eater of a man yeah sure
yes a polar bear a gentle polar bear
right you get angry unless you get angry
then I'm pulling a walrus up onto the
iceberg using nothing but the strength
of my jaws and you can google that video
and and your kids won't sleep at night
okay but I'll tell you this much another
thing that we're changing about the bond
role is generally that's gone to a white
guy so now we're doing that a little
differently yeah with me you're a white
guy I'm a hundred percent Italian so
please don't be a real well yeah I'm not
that's you can be a racist piece of [ __ ]
yeah you're pretty damn white you got
blue eyes now yeah I know
by now that I'm Italian so that's Dan
again probably not probably more of a
Serb right hmm you probably know I'm
from my parents are from Napoli from
nature him over from Serbia you're a
giant Serbian own giant Serbian bear
you're a Serbian bear did you say
Serbian bear I said to Serbia I'm not a
Serbian bear
we're breaking new ground with bond I'm
looking really forward to playing him
and yeah yeah something something
British accent I'll do my research just
like a stalker is with James Bond that's
right they're not stir totally [ __ ] you
should have been at the audition shaken
not stirred and mash bomb yeah I was
thinking about coming up with some new
lines for it like like [ __ ] I'm
coming in there I doesn't sound be
careful I'm coming in there that's a
really shrill voice if there's you bring
it down a little
yeah you know a friend of mine once said
that oh that you know why that guy's not
a movie star he's got a boy voice he was
tough though he's talking about some
other act he's got a boy it's got a boy
voice it's true though isn't it